ENO COMPTON: Let's
deploy a container
to Google Compute Engine.
To keep things simple, we will
deploy an nginx container.
Before deploying
the container, we
need to configure a firewall
rule to allow incoming HTTP
traffic on port 80.
We add a target
tag of HTTP server
so we can associate our
container with this rule
in the next step.
The firewall rule
configured, we are
ready to deploy our container.
We'll name our VM nginx VM.
We'll add the HTTP
server tag from the step
before to associate the created
VM with the firewall rule,
and we will specify
our container image.
The create-with-container
command
starts a container using
the host's network.
This means we don't need to
provide any port mappings.
Now, let's test it.
And with that, we have
a container running
on Google Compute Engine.